La amenaza de una escalada por parte de
Rusia y el uso de armas nucleares es
cada vez más latente qué podemos esperar
lo que podemos hacer pero es una
continuidad de los ataques rusos contra
blancos civiles y blancos de
infraestructura usando básicamente
misiles cruceros y drons de fabricación
iraní y otro de fabricación rusa
las estados Rusia va a seguir acumulando
digamos fuerzas terrestres con vistas a
colocarlas en el terreno para operarlas
después del Invierno ahora estamos en un
periodo de lluvias y de barro que va a
extenderse de fines de octubre a
noviembre Eso después se va a congelar
en el invierno Así que van a ser cuatro
meses donde las grandes operaciones
terrestres se van a detener Ucrania
tiene dos o tres semanas más para
moverse con cierta facilidad en el
terreno y después va a haber un parate
de las grandes operaciones y creo que
Rusia va a tratar de durante todo este
periodo de barro de Lluvia de invierno
provocar el mayor castigo a la
infraestructura y a la población civil
ucraniana y esperar que efectos tiene el
invierno en la política europea las
turbulencias la crisis las de la
búsqueda de algún tipo de solución por
presiones políticas y después en abril
una batalla seguramente si no hay un
acuerdo de paz una batalla campal ya no
con 200 mil hombres de cada lado sino
con más de medio millón de hombres de
cada lado
precisamente decía al presidente de
bolodimir selenski que Rusia ha perdido
todo su potencial militar refiriéndose a
los avances que ha tenido en su
contraofensiva qué tan precisa son estas
afirmaciones
sin duda la fuerza terrestre rusa están
tan replegándose están en una situación
muy complicada Yo creo que la el medio
ambiente el clima la lluvia y el barro
va a evitar que Ucrania pueda avanzar
más y además porque la propia Ucrania no
puede extender mucho a sus líneas
logísticas es un ejército No todavía de
las dimensiones que puede llegar a tener
el año que viene como el ruso donde se
puede duplicar o duplicar yo creo que va
a recuperar un poco más yo creo que
deberán objetivo ucraniano antes de las
temporadas de lluvias y de Barros es
tener una posición dominante En Carson
que sería muy importante porque la
colocarían las puertas de digamos de la
zona Sur que da a crimea sería un golpe
simbólico muy fuerte para
controlar a Riberas del niéper un río
muy importante donde hay una Represa muy
importante que está en manos rusas y hay
versiones serias que se Represa podría
ser abierta o detonada en el caso que
los ucranianos lograran avanzar mucho
más
pero de ahí a decir que la fuerza rusas
no tienen más capacidad no la fuerza
rusa se han recibido una derrota
estratégica muy importante de que
fracasaron en conquistar el país en
pocos días como le ordenó Putin creo que
al contrario de lo que le recomendaba
los mandos militares que no eran hacer
una operación de tanta magnitud Pero
bueno puti metió la mano y se decidió
una operación de larga escala que no
anduvo evidentemente ahora la gran
pregunta es podrá Ucrania recuperar
estos territorios anexados
unilateralmente por Rusia sosteniendo en
cuenta la situación en crimea que piensa
usted
no yo creo que Estados Unidos que es el
gran negociador acá y que está
negociando intensamente con Rusia de
hecho la Bros estuvo cinco días en
Washington con agenda secreta el
canciller ruso esta semana se hablaron
dos veces los ministros de defensa de
Rusia y de Estados Unidos
telefónicamente no hablaban desde mayo
yo creo que parte del acuerdo que se va
a ir gestando con Estados Unidos como
como pieza principal es que obviamente
la ofensiva rusa no va no va a tener que
llegar a Ucrania y que al menos parte
sustancial o no todo de lo que conquistó
Rusia en el 2014 va a quedar en manos en
manos rusas obviamente eso va a ser un
trago difícil de digerir para Ucrania va
a provocar mucho ruido en Ucrania pero
rojo Ucrania se queda con algo no menor
que saber Derrotado estratégicamente a
Rusia y haber recuperado parte
sustancial O quizá todo lo que ocupó
Rusia después del 24 de febrero del 2022